[Music]
hey you guys time once again for the
matinee show this is matinee 69 yes I
can't even remember I can't even
remember what movies it was well it was
a couple of NetFlow it was a Netflix
movie Netflix series and one that we saw
in the theater oh I wouldn't okay we
name them off
sweetheart is the first one though so we
saw enough look says monster movie Ari's
which is a horror series yeah and the
turning also we saw underwater for a
second time if you want to like throw in
on that too but yeah that's like not one
of the official yeah I can't I
understand that I can't understand that
movie at all that was bought during that
damn Disney merger with Disney and Fox I
was at Fox and Disney that merge it was
some [ __ ] like that and Disney Disney
owns it and they didn't make it so they
just said [ __ ] it they didn't they
didn't promote it hardly they do it in
the middle of a January you know with
all the other shitty movies that come
out in January and I had only opened it
only played in the US and Canada they
didn't send it to Europe yet it may be
by now by the time that this yeah
because sometimes I mean I've heard
about movies that like it was like six
months later like it opened in Europe
sometimes it opens like at the same time
but most of the time it's later yeah and
then this movie with that movie was made
in 2017 yeah I think it's been earlier
it was finished in our pre-production
was done in 2017 it was finished in 2018
something like that
so before we start Matney I'm gonna give
it a second shout out go check out oh I
liked it better the second time I caught
a bunch of stuff that I'm yeah the first
time yeah the movie stood up to multiple
viewings it is not a complicated movie
it's just a good old-fashioned [ __ ]
movie kind of like aliens yeah
underwater people yeah you know I got
some friends online you know that I know
from the close in that just look abyss
and it is not like abyss it's more like
alien I liked it better than them yeah I
remember seeing the abyss in the theatre
yeah yes and it has a weird ending to
where you like oh is that what this was
and then it's it you could it's kind of
like it was set in the same universe is
Blade
an alien you know Ridley Scott's future
yeah I would say very much into the
future maybe two you know it didn't seem
all that futurist wasn't all that be
just some of this the constructions and
some of the suits look like maybe it's
like 20 years from now yeah something
like that it was pretty cool yeah but
yeah so we just we just wanted to go in
and say yeah good acting we actually
went and saw that a second good acting
good characters special effects stood up
it it just was a fun movie to watch yeah
it was alright so the first we're gonna
talk about is a Netflix movie this is
called sweetheart now this actually I
believe it premiered at a film festival
like way back at the beginning of 2019
but it actually didn't get to streaming
services I think it debuted on streaming
like the end of October but I don't
think it came to Netflix until December
so I just now got around to seeing it
now this is uh from Blum House
production so you know they're they're
kind of hit or miss with the horror
movies but you know this one I actually
really liked it a lot it's essentially a
creature feature which I guess it's not
really spoiling it because they're
because the trailer shows but it's it's
a very simple like survival story
basically at the very beginning of the
story you get this young woman named Jen
who has washed ashore on a presumably
abandoned Island and they don't really
tell you until later on you don't know
if she was diving or you know it you
know by I assumed that she was in a boat
right because she didn't have a diamond
so you don't or anything like that so
and she you know she's washed up with
somebody else like a friend of hers that
was apparently traveling with her and he
ends up dying and then she has to like
survive on this island on her own until
like rescue comes she does see like
planes going by overhead and stuff like
that so she knows that she probably has
a chance of getting out but so the first
part of the movie is kind of her
figuring out like what she's gonna do
like she finds stuff that I guess there
were people that had been stranded there
previously like a long time ago so she
found finds like a cooler was like old
coke in it like an old ripped up tent
and stuff like that so she does have
some supplies like a couple of matches
and stuff so as the days go on and she's
kind of like trying to find food and
everything and waiting for rescue it
comes to pass that something is coming
out of the water at night an eating [ __ ]
on the island yeah including the body of
the friend that had died after they
washed up and she said she buried like
he gets all torn up and so she starts to
kind of like you know she started making
Spears and stuff like that they don't
really show the monster but it's kind of
like you just see like flickers of it or
like shadows and stuff like that they
don't show it like full-on until the end
so you don't know exactly what it is now
the cool thing about this movie though
is that I don't want to spoil too much
about it like I said it's a pretty
simple survival story of like this woman
on this island you know trying not to
get eaten by this monster or trying to
kill this monster but there are a couple
of other complicating factors that
happen like later on that hint it may be
like a wider story like so the cool
thing about it is that you can just
watch it as like a simple monster movie
and it's very good like that it's very
fast-paced it's only about an hour about
an hour and 20 minutes long something
like that very well edited they shot it
on in Fiji somewhere I believe so it's
like really gorgeous like all the island
locations and everything so all the
cinematography is really nice
particularly the first um the first like
reveal of the monster where you just see
like she puts up a flare because she
sees like a plane going over at night so
she shoots up a flare and as like the
the red flare like comes down the beach
she sees like this big shadowed kind of
monster coming out of the water and
starts flipping the [ __ ] out so it was
like a really effective introduction of
the monster that she's gonna be fighting
but so like I said the cool thing about
it is that you can just watch it as a
really enjoyable fast paced monster
maybe with like some good gore and and
stuff like that but then there's like
hints that you know something else might
be going on or something bigger might be
going on and I like that they didn't
really explain some of the things you
know what I mean yeah I don't want to
get too much into it cuz like I said the
complicating factors that have been
later on they don't
let out yeah but you can read a lot of
different things into it which I thought
was really cool but like I said you
could take it or leave it it doesn't you
don't have to pick up on it it's a
monster movie in the way that the
predator was a monster movie it reminded
me a bit of them yeah it's it's not an
alien you know you just gotta wait to
the end till you see it but you know the
the and it's kind of a lower budget of
course it's a lower budget then yeah
they're predatory and predator had a
bunch of dudes in there you know fully
[ __ ] jacked and decked out with
[ __ ] cool weapons it's just this
black chick trying to make it on her own
and so you know didn't quite cost as
much to to make this movie there's a
bunch of firefights and you know like
daddy yeah because she's basically like
whatever she washed up with yes like off
her boat or whatever was like a castaway
isn't that called yes yes she's the
castaway on this damn desert island and
there's something coming after she's
gotta figure out how to survive it it's
pretty good yeah good and I really liked
Kiersey Clemons place that was all good
plays the main woman and I like that
there's not actually not a lot of
dialogue in this as you would probably
expect because for a large part of the
movie she's on the island by herself so
you know she doesn't talk to herself or
anything like that she basically just
gets [ __ ] done I like that she doesn't I
mean as soon as she washed up on the
island and understands what's going on
she doesn't like oh [ __ ] oh poor me
anything like that she just immediately
gets into okay well I got to drag this
friend here I got to help him and then
like yeah you know he dies he's like
okay well now I need to explore that I
need to find water I need to find
something I need to do this at that in
the other so she doesn't like spend a
lot of time like you know I feel like a
lot of movies where people are put in
situations like this like spend a lot of
time it's like character development
they'll spend a lot of time with the
character going oh no no I gonna do but
she does not do that at all she's just
like oh okay well actually the analogy
is is that she's basically if you know
and pretty much everybody seen the movie
predator she's basically Arnold in the
final part of the movie when all the
friends are dead arms trying to make it
on his own with
damn weapons against something that's
dangerous it's bigger than her and it's
dangerous
yeah and she doesn't know much about it
it's pretty cool yeah she doesn't know
what it is she's just kind of like oh
she knows what it can do and she's just
trying to figure out how to survive what
the thing can do you know it's it's this
is this isn't this is an original I
don't think it's Netflix original now it
might be Netflix exclusive I'm not sure
although I think I saw it on YouTube
streaming to like for pay paying the
rental or whatever yeah but yeah they do
have it on on Netflix right now if you
want to watch it like I said it's very
fast-paced I really liked it a lot I
feel like predator you'd probably like
it yeah because it's a very similar kind
of tone just survival horror yeah it's
just not as flashy you know it doesn't
have a military flair to it yeah and
like you said it's very low-budget but
really the cinematography the
cinematography and stuff and the CGI
what little there was of it I think they
use some CGI and some practical effects
for the monster but it looks really good
like furs presumably low-budget as as
well yes so yeah I would definitely
recommend this especially if you're into
Creature Features and haven't seen it a
good one in a long time this was
actually a pretty decent one so
recommended
you
all right and the next thing that we
watch this week was also on Netflix a
Netflix original series although it is
Dutch it is called Aras now this
actually it's eight episode so the
episodes are short they're only about 30
minutes long so it's about a four hour
whole series I don't know if they're
doing in a second season I mean I feel
like it could go either way like it I
like the way they ended it but there's
room to expand if they want to do that
so this basically it's kind of like if
cuz I watch the trailer I'm like ooh
that gives me like an Eyes Wide Shut
kind of vibe I'm done with that so so I
started watching it and it's like I I
saw like a lot of reviews on on it and
like a lot of people like in YouTube
comments it's up like that going you
know I really like the show but I have
no [ __ ] idea what's going on well
like to me it seemed pretty obvious like
what all the sin in it like all the
symbolism was and everything like that
and reading a little bit about like
other people that watched it we're
actually Dutch and that we're talking
about like various cultural things so it
came into like a lot of sharp relief
like what the what it was actually about
like I said I'm not gonna spoil it
because I do actually recommend it if
you like this kind of like Illuminati
like secret society type of thing
because that's definitely what this is
so it basically follows this girl young
woman really named Rosa Steen wake and
she lives in Amsterdam and she is a
first year medical student very early in
the film it's established she comes from
like kind of like a lower middle class
middle class family her dad looks like I
think he's a doctor as well or a nurse
or something
her mom is crazy that's terrible to say
but like has some mental issues has done
like you know suicide attempts and is on
various medications and stuff and it
almost seems like Rosa is like trying to
get away from her family like she
doesn't like the burden of it and she's
also really really ambitious like she
wants to become a doctor like the best
at everything so she's very very like
high achieving and wants to like feels
like she deserves more in life than you
know where she comes
perhaps so it transpires that her best
childhood friend whose name is Jakob he
is involved with this what is at first
thought to be like a secret student
society kind of like Skull and Bones or
something like that called Aras and
she's kind of intrigued about it
although Jakob who I guess he's not like
fully in it but he's like a novice or
he's like you know trying out for it or
something
now he tries to talk her out of it you
know what I mean
but she's kind of like well if
somebody's trying to talk me out of it
like I need to find out what the [ __ ]
this is all about so she starts like
pushing her way into it and like trying
to figure out what it is and it turns
out that it's this it's a secret society
that meets in this like it's really
really cool like big creepy like old
gothic pile and they're all all of the
members are you know kind of from really
wealthy powerful families in Holland and
she's the only one that isn't so as the
series goes on you kind of figure out
like why they wanted her to be in this
thing what this society is exactly there
is like a supernatural element to it
because there's there's like all these
kind of things where people are like
barfing up like black goop are like
black eggs there's presumably you think
that there's like this demon or
something like chained in the basement
of the place you know Jakob at one point
like touches this wall and it makes his
fingers turn black and then he can like
touch people and it makes them like go
crazy and like all these suicides start
happening and people start blaming her
so it's this really kind of
multi-layered thing about you know her
joining this society and what the hell
they are and what they're trying to do
you know what I mean so if you are
really into these sort of like these
halves like European like series like if
you liked dark the German one which is
excellent this is not like a sci-fi this
is basically more like straight-up
gothic horror eyes wide shut type of
illuminati type of [ __ ] with kind of a
supernatural element to it if you liked
there's stuff like beyond the walls
which I think was Belgian stuff like
that so it has like very much that kind
of like European gothic type of vibe you
know secret society all that kind of
stuff so if you dig that and like I said
you got to pay attention to a lot of the
symbolism like where she first meets up
with the society like the paintings that
they're looking at and stuff like that
you really have to like you look at what
the painting is of like to see like what
they're talking about like with the eggs
and everything yeah it was well made it
is it's really nice looking at it it's
good looking movie personally I couldn't
get into it yeah I was watching as well
yeah okay whatever that's not really my
kind of thing yeah maybe a lot when
you're watching these things a mood has
a lot to do with it yeah employees
refuge for for these before the show
Jenny and I have to watch all this stuff
in a pretty short period of time so I
can't really take my time with a series
I go get me take a break and go back
well we dim you binge watch the whole
thing pretty much thing we saw it until
I watched over two nights I watched like
the first four episodes the first night
and then the second and you know if
something really doesn't doesn't catch
my attention in the first 15 minutes it
never really will yeah that's just how I
and like I said this one was one that
and patience for this and because it was
in Dutch and there was like a lot of
stuff that was like kind of that like I
said I didn't really know until I read
some other like people that actually
were Dutch that we're commenting on
certain things like oh that old woman
that was behind the glass she was
speaking medieval Dutch she wasn't
speaking modern Dutch which you wouldn't
know if you were in a Dutch speaker and
that like points to what her character
was or what her character represented so
there's a lot of stuff that I think is a
little bit lost in translation to an
American thing but like I said I didn't
really have any problem following the
symbolism of it in general there was
probably like a few little things like I
said it was like you know cultural that
I didn't pick up on but the you know the
message of the the overriding theme of
it I thought was pretty clear although
apparently I'm you know cause like I
said I sell books to people that said oh
I really
but what the [ __ ] did it mean you know
what I mean but it's like to me it
seemed pretty clear baby I don't know if
other people might not find it that way
but yeah so if you're like into that
type of thing like I said it's only
about four hours like altogether because
there's eight episodes but they're only
half an hour long it moves along pretty
quick like I said it wraps up pretty
satisfyingly but it still has space to
go if it wanted to go to a season two
which it may or may not I don't really
know but um yeah so if you're into that
kind of thing I would recommend it Tom
wasn't into it but I know it's not
really his kind of thing but I liked it
a lot so
you
all right and the third movie that we
saw this week we saw in the theater this
is the new movie the turning now this
yeah here this is like okay this kind of
bummed me out because here's the thing I
I really like the original novel the
turn of the screw I even you guys I even
I read it a long time ago but I even
realism to the audio book only like a
few hours before we went to see the
movie because I was curious like to see
how close it was because there was a lot
of plot details I had forgotten about
so I went into this with the novella you
know still very fresh in the back of my
head because I'd only listen to it the
just a couple of hours before now I had
been seeing you know trailers for this
for like a while so I was kind of
looking forward to them like you know it
might be good it might not be otherwise
very good it looked like it would be
okay it looked like you know I said well
it's not exactly like the book because I
could already tell from some of the
trailers but I was like maybe it'll be a
good adaptation we'll see and when we
were watching it I was like wow this is
pretty good it's like it's it's a loose
adaptation I'm gonna say that it's like
there's a lot of [ __ ] that's changed
from the book which I might get into a
little bit later yeah but I got I like
this movie up until all the way up to
that last [ __ ] three minutes the last
three watch it I was like what the [ __ ]
basically this this movie makes the
cardinal sin of it was all a dream kind
of ears all exact it's not exactly what
it is
Victoria the instead of the and she woke
up and it was all a dream for a version
well it's not only that angle what they
did was is they ended it with a [ __ ]
be crazy ankle which [ __ ] was crazy
which like I said okay now I know ghost
[ __ ] is crazy
I should say that this movie this movie
has had I mean probably I I feel like I
don't think that the fault of this it
wasn't the actors cuz all the actors
were good I don't even know if it was
the director this to me and I don't know
if this is true or not this to me smacks
of post-production studio interference
I suspect the audience laugh
at this movie well I've heard I've been
watching some other reviews and some
other people have said the same thing
that when they went to see in the
theater people were either like what let
the forgive the [ __ ] out of here or
something like that we're reacting
similarly to the end yeah yeah which
yeah yeah and here's the thing well they
should have yeah and it wasn't even like
the movie itself like watching the whole
movie if it had had a different ending
it probably would have been perfectly
fun when it gave you two endings the
movie was [ __ ] awesome and then it
had an ending you like yeah and then all
the sudden he goes no no no it gives you
an alternate ending that [ __ ] it was
it was very weird the way they sucked
all the air out of the [ __ ] story she
like so I watch this [ __ ] for nothing
[ __ ] was crazy it was crazy it was kind
of like you know so how sometimes I see
soup you know how sometimes you see some
of those comedies and like somebody will
like they'll be like a wacky situation
and then they'll stop and they'll say to
the audience now here's how this
happened and then that's kind of what
she did at the end of this yeah um okay
now essentially like I said this movie
you know it was actually directed by a
floor Floria Sigismond II who actually
she did a bunch of like music videos in
the 90s for like David Bowie and Marilyn
Manson and stuff like that she also did
the movie The Runaways which actually I
really liked that you know was about the
band it's like a band biopic which
person Stewart and it was also an
underwater but like I said I feel like
it wasn't even I mean the cinematography
and this is really nice they said it in
1994 for some strange reason maybe
because so there's no cell phones I
would guess also I read that there's
because I mean the turn of the screw by
Henry James which came out in 1898 has
had like a zillion billion million
[ __ ] adaptations like as far as I
know it's like nine movies it had a
bunch of TV series
it had an opera for Christ's sake a
couple of ballets and actually the
interesting thing is that the Netflix
series the haunting of Hill House the
Mike Flanagan one season two is gonna be
based on the turn of the screw which
hopefully I'm sure it will be better
than this this really bummed me out
because like I said
everybody and this was good fin wolfhard
was good Mackenzie Davis was good
because the little girl Brooklyn printed
she was great good acting yeah yeah
everything was good the cinematography
was good - name of that what's the name
of the girl which one the one that was
in that boy she's been in two shitty
movies that [ __ ] recently she was in
was it terminator abomination its boy
that wasn't what was the name of what
was the name of that Terminator movie
dark fate dark fate that's right dad
Kenzi davis her name is what was good in
that movie well she's been in a bunch of
other stuff too
um she was in this one she's cute in
this one I mean she's been in a bunch of
like really good prestige - yes you like
Daryl Hannah yeah and it's like so the
thing that I feel like okay now um I'm
assuming like I you know I hate to be
like Oh spoilers and everything but come
on this is based on the turn of the
screw I thought everybody kind of knew
the story of that so I don't really feel
that I mean come on then not no more
than a hundred years a lot of people
don't know that story but I'm just
saying that you know and there have been
so many adaptations of it probably the
best the closest and the most
well-regarded is from 1961 the innocence
with Deborah Carr movie which is
actually yet which is a great horror
movie item but also one of the closest
adaptations to the actual book so okay I
feel like what they tried to do in this
and this is why I suspect that it was
you know post-production you know studio
interference I think what happened
because the whole point of Henry James's
novel was that he never tells you if the
ghosts are real or if the governess who
is actually not named in the book
because it's from her perspective or if
the governess is just nuts but people do
die and there is evidence that [ __ ]
happened in it it's just that you don't
know if that's just subjective or what
and it's kind of like it's Victorian it
was a time when there was a lot of
spiritism going on and seances and if
you ask me the the Victorian story ended
with [ __ ] be crazy that's what it
really meant because I think I was
saying all this spiritism and all this
that it's not true and that these
[ __ ] are crazy well see that because
that's how they were about gonna victim
the thing about it that you could never
prove it one way or the
yeah well I think Henry James did that
very deliberately yeah because you could
read it in at least two different ways
and each of those two different ways has
a couple of different variations like
you could either say it was all in the
governesses head yeah you could say that
the ghosts were real and everything she
perceived was entirely correct that big
that the children also saw the ghost but
were reluctant to say so you could say
that the kids were driving her crazy by
saying by talking about the ghost or
somebody because like a lot of the stuff
that the kids said was kind of
double-edged sword type of stuff so he
never takes a stand either way and I
think he did that on purpose just so you
know because he was kind of tribe
because I feel like this stuff about
later on when you know people talk about
the turn of the screw as you know an
example of an unreliable narrator um I
don't know if that came about until a
few decades after it was written I think
you know like in the 1930s but I
definitely think that Henry James wrote
it to be deliberately ambiguous although
that ol boy dying at the end was not
ambiguous just that you're not really
sure why he died but because everybody
banned the ghosts I think it might have
been well seize no because the thing is
what you're doing like the novel and
they didn't do this in in the movie
adaptation the novel is actually it has
like a foreword where there's a guy who
is talking about who's it's like
Christmas Eve and they're all telling
ghost stories like the Victorians do and
you know somebody had told one and it
wasn't that great and he's like oh I've
got the worst [ __ ] story ever it
happened to a friend of mine but you
guys will have to wait a couple of
nights because she wrote it all down
before she died and it's in my you know
safe deposit box or whatever the [ __ ]
and then he has to go get it and then so
he kind of like builds it up so then
after that you don't lit you don't hear
from that guy anymore the everything
else is her written recollection of what
happened to her that fly out of the
house is probably that book right so
you're only seeing things from her
perspective and in the book she
as far as you can tell is the only one
that sees the ghosts she perceives that
the children can see them but they don't
tell you either way yeah but but with
this movie you have to confuse the issue
with this movie the way that ending is
set up that [ __ ] was crazy well yeah
that's what I mean and so I feel like
there's no ambiguity in it really yeah
an ID and Elise my understanding of that
ending that's how I that's how I took it
and if I'm if I'm misunderstanding it
then the movie failed because the movie
should make it clear to the audience
that it was ambiguous well the thing it
wasn't clear that was ambiguous it was
clear to me that that [ __ ] is crazy
what I think happened and like I said
this is this is what I was trying to say
when I was saying that I suspect this is
probably studio interference I kind of
expect because this movie I mean Steven
Spielberg was attached at the beginning
because they've started about talking
about doing this like back in 2016 it's
gone through a couple of directors a
couple different script rewrites and I
feel like they probably wanted to make
it more faithful to the book in the
sense of making it ambiguous so they
would never come down on the side of are
the ghosts real or is she crazy just
like the book does however I feel like
they maybe they made it like that and
then they showed it to test audiences
and test audiences look well would well
is she crazy or is it goes would it
would want to pick one of the other so
that is crazy then they had to go and
like I said you know the original novel
a lot of people have speculated that yes
she is probably an unreliable narrator
and yes it was like a symptom of her
psycho sexual repression that she was
seeing these ghosts and she was trying
to protect the innocence like the
innocent children from the corruption of
the ghosts but that was all in her
perception like the way she perceived it
and she was like slowly going mad the
whole time she was there yeah so you
know so that's not like an unprecedented
interpretation of the story a lot of
people have interpreted it that way and
some other film adaptations have done it
that way but I just feel like it wasn't
so much that they decided to come down
definitively on the side
[ __ ] be crazy yeah but I just feel I
don't like the way they did it it just
seemed like some other reviewers I've
said they said it seems like it's not
finished it definitely did have a very
strange like it was very strange the way
they put that across I feel like if you
were going to make a stand on that you
know fair enough I prefer it ambiguous
but I know that a lot of people don't
like that so it's like if they wanted to
you go yes she's crazy she didn't see
any the ghosts or anything like that
then there was a better way of doing it
should have just left it though the
ghost for real live audience would have
liked that a lot more oh yeah how's the
audience audience wanted it to go yeah
there were ghosts yeah they went the
wrong direction if you're gonna make it
definitive make it that the ghosts for
real yeah don't make it that she's
[ __ ] crazy
because then there's no point in the
movie well yeah then everybody man and
then all that [ __ ] that I was all that
[ __ ] that I saw didn't even happen you
know I mean that that's how they reacted
yeah so no the movie was a failure but
yeah I think they know it's a failure
it's why they put it in [ __ ] January
probably because like I said they've
they've been like you know this has had
a very troubled production history and
like I said I feel really bad because I
don't even think that this was a it
almost seems like it was a failure and
the editing process in the
post-production process because it feels
like it was something that it's almost
kind of like it was made by committee
yeah you know what I mean acting is good
he's good about it he set the start the
ending of the damn story I mean they
changed a lot of stuff from the novel
like they you know they made you know
Finn Wolfe hards character of miles they
made him much older than he was in the
book obviously in the book he was only
ten he's now he's like a sullen teenager
he's more of a threat in this book in
the movie whereas in the book the kid
was very sweet and angelic or at least
that was how the governess perceived in
so they changed some things
they changed the relationship between
the governess and although she's a nanny
in this one because it's in the 90s and
mrs. grose the housekeeper like they
were actually friends in the book in
this one they're kind of like you know
at loggerheads sort of or mrs. Grose is
kind of like very condescending toward
her you know so there's like little
changes like that made but I don't I
don't have a problem with that
necessarily it just
seems like like I said it seemed like
they wanted to have ambiguity and not at
the same time and they didn't know how
to do that was a bad ass story and
everything I liked it and then it ended
she fought the ghosts and everything it
ended no mess that was pretty good it's
pretty good movie they don't Sun up nope
here's another ending and any like know
that [ __ ] is crazy
oh man [ __ ] this it definitely feels
like Tim liked the book and credit
started to roll and they got the ghost
and then win the damn water and the
whole audience stat there and went
through all those down and was like
saying there's waiting force is there
gonna be something after the credits
missile like it's not no yeah because
everyone just sat there and I are
waiting waiting is there more is there
more what happened what was what with
you know we're the ghosts real do you
know we don't see it it seemed like okay
you know how sometimes you see the
movies is and they have and they shoot
like a bunch of alternate endings to
[ __ ] to show to different test audiences
right it to me it feels like they did
that except they made two or three
different endings and then they just
took this one in has just tacked it on
the end yeah they should have had that
on there they just attacked it it just
basically just seems like it's tacked on
the end and it doesn't have to be there
I mean they could have just ended it
where it was without that it was stupid
but like I said and that's a shame
because I really like that book and it's
like I you know I thought you know oh
they could do a modern reinterpretation
of it like I said now I'm sure I'm sure
Mike Flanagan is probably like really
happy because he's like well [ __ ] now my
adaptation doesn't even have to be that
good because it's like it'll look much
better by comparison you know what I
mean even though I'm sure that was gonna
be a shot at stuff in a day it really
did it's and like I said it's a shame
because that was like the only thing I
mean up to then it was written by the
two guys that wrote the conjuring which
you know it was it had a lot of jump
scares and stuff like that but it had a
cool like creepy atmosphere you know the
acting was good there was like a lot of
Menace like between like you know the
kid rapey as ghosts
yeah like yeah rapey ghosts and stuff
like that which is like I said that's
kind of a little bit implied in the
original novel so they're not pulling it
out of their ass or anything like that
it's all in there in the book it's just
very understated ghosts rape and other
ghosts yeah so it's looking pretty cool
so it's like and I like that they in a
way I like that they made Myles his
character a little bit older
so that you kind of got because well I
mean in the novel the ten-year-old kid
there's a little bit of that going on
too but I mean it's Victorian so it's
very understated but a lot of the
undercurrent of their relationship is
sort of like that and like a lot of the
stuff that he says is sort of like that
but it's much creepier because he's much
younger in this one you know Myles seems
like more of a threat because he's older
you know what I mean so I I kind of like
the way they did that even though they
changed his character pretty much
entirely from the novel but you know
like I said they could do changes but I
just feel like the ending just ruined it
if it didn't have that tacked on ending
if they had just ended it you know the
way they were gonna end it before they
were like oh but no this is what really
happened then
then this wouldn't've been it wouldn't
have been like a fantastic movie or even
a particularly good adaptation but it
would have been like a decent it had
been a better water movie yeah yeah yeah
it would have just been like an
entertaining you we talk too much about
this throwaway horrible painting
ourselves and we're spending too much
time on that on this movie it's not
worth it yeah it's it's a shame but you
know [ __ ] happens
you